la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur les présidents prêt dans deux
commissions madame la reporter chers
collègues
cette initiative madame la ministre
c'est une initiative transpartisane qui
doit beaucoup d'ailleurs et je tiens à
le préciser à le saluer à notre collègue
jean pierre sueur c'est une initiative
transpartisane donc rare il faut donc la
souligner
il ne s'agit pas de nier d'ailleurs les
différences que nous avions entre nous
vous pouvez compter sur moi pour tenir
ferme sur nos convictions
il ne s'agit pas non plus eu madame la
ministre il ne s'agit pas non plus de se
liguer en quelque sorte contre le
gouvernement pour vous jouer un mauvais
coup pas du tout vous nous donner
régulièrement des occasions de nous
opposer il s'agit simplement de nous
rassembler sur ce que nous considérons
être un socle commun de conviction et
cela peut arriver et heureusement nous
ne sommes pas en guerre civile nous
sommes en france dans un même hémicycle
et ses convictions qui sont des
convictions communes concerne à la fois
cette conception du rôle du parlement et
la conception aussi du rôle de l'état la
caisse et la conception sur les droits
du parlement il s'agit pour nous d'une
question de forme mais qui est
fondamental
jamais sous la vème république un
gouvernement n'aura autant recourir aux
ordonnances je suis d'inspiration
gaulliste et je sais qu'on a besoin d
ordonnance mais vous avez franchi tous
les cas
304 ordonnance publiée contestez-vous ce
chiffre
en même temps si j'ose dire vous avez de
moins en moins recours à la ratification
cinquante cinq ordonnances ratifiées
contestez vous madame ce chiffre si vous
ne connaissez pas ces deux chiffres ce
que je veux dire c'est que en matière de
publications d'ordonnancé on est
déjà au 30 septembre à 150 % de plus par
rapport à l'avant dernier quinquennat et
quand vous ratifiez 55 ordonnant ça
signifie que 18 % seulement de ces
ordonnances moins de 20% mes chers
collègues sont désormais ratifié ça
signifie que le gouvernement gouverne
fait la loi en dehors du parlement
certes la constitution l'autorisé mais
sans pour autant recourir au parlement
pour ratifier les ordonnances alors même
que l'article 38 un boutre à ce qui
avait été rajoutée par la dernière
révision constitutionnelle est très
claire elle ne peuvent s'y ordonnance
être ratifié que de manière expresse au
namm la ministre j'ai lu ce matin comme
un certain nombre d'entre nous vos
propos je veux dire que votre
déclaration est une insulte au parlement
c'est un mépris total
[Applaudissements]
c'est
une insulte lorsque nous sommes
individuellement nous ne sommes rien si
peu de choses
c'est une insulte pour ce que nous
sommes collectivement nous représentons
les français nous sommes la
représentation nationale je vais vous
dire masque est un ouvrage ce qui est un
naufrage voyez c'est un gouvernement qui
refuse jusqu au débat c'est un autre
c'est un naufrage d'un exécutif qui
dénie le la seule possibilité de
débattre au parlement c'est aussi un
naufrage pour un exécutif qui va
rechercher la responsabilité pour des
fossés de la sienne auprès d'un bouc
émissaire que serait la haute fonction
publique voilà où il est le naufrage
madame ministre il est là le naufrage et
je veux le dire solennellement à cette
tribune il ya des questions de forme qui
touche aux droits du parlement mais il
ya beaucoup plus il ya beaucoup plus
parce que touché à la voûte
l'administration c'est toucher à
l'administration est touché à
l'administration c'est toucher aussi à
l'état et au rôle qu'on se fait à la
conception durs concède de l'état alors
évidemment entre c'est bon vous avez
différentes conceptions de l'état nous
avons à plusieurs reprises fait des
propositions sur le temps de travail sur
le statut nous sommes pour le statut
mais sur les fonctions régaliennes mais
oui madame la ministre devriez lire plus
souvent nos déclarations et même un
certain nombre de textes nous sommes
pour le recours certes plus large à une
contractualisation en dehors de ses
fonctions régaliennes
mais voyez on s'accorde sans doute ici
quelles que soient les bancs sur une
certitude c'est que une réforme de l'ena
ne fait pas une réforme de l'état et si
vous avez recours dans la précipitation
à six mois des élections présidentielles
c'est sans doute pour masquer à toute
vitesse le peu de choses que vous avez
fait sur la réforme de l'état où sont
d'ailleurs ces promesses du président de
la république il devait y avoir moins
cinquante mille postes de supprimer
pendant ce quinquennat il y en aura-t-il
simplement un seul nous en discuterons
dans le projet de loi de finances bien
évidemment mais ce que je veux
simplement ajouter aussi c'est que cette
réforme risque d'être le sommet de l' en
même temps une sorte de dents même temps
archétypale sur la haute fonction
publique et notamment sur les corps le
corps préfectoral qui a tenu l'état
pendant la crise et gilet jaune si ce ne
sont les forces de l'ordre avec le corps
préfectoral qui à part les systèmes vote
premier ministre de ce fameux couple
maire préfère bien le corps préfectoral
ça n'est pas une sinécure ce n'est pas
un titre ce n'est pas une charge c'est
une longue expérience et une école c'est
un apprentissage de l'état régalien
commandé des troupes des pompiers des
policiers des gendarmes ça s'apprend eh
bien je vais vous dire votre réforme
sans doute n'y at il plus de corps mais
vous allez devoir faire une usine à gaz
pour habituera la même chose en créant
un cadre d'emplois est en réalité rien
ne changera comme disait visconti ce
sera ça le en même temps de votre
réforme derrière votre réforme il ya
beaucoup plus il ya de remise en cause
une première remise en cause qui est
celle de l'état tels que général de
gaulle l'a voulu tel qu'il a refondé la
vème république il s'exprime c'était à
alger en juillet 44 il dit dans l'ordre
politique
notre choix c'est la démocratie et c'est
la république il va plus loin il
explicite la démocratie c'est rendre la
parole au peuple on voit ce que cela
signifie et la république c'est remettre
sur pied l'administration
autour du gouvernement à paris mais
aussi localement donc on voit bien que
ils chargent général de gaulle cette
administration et notamment la haute
fonction publique d'une mission
particulière c'est celle qui compte qui
consiste à articuler de temporalité de
cycle le cycle court de l'élection de la
démocratie avec le cycle long le cycle
de la république de la permanence est ce
que vous faites ce que vous allez faire
est ce que nous vous reprocheront c'est
le risque d'enfermer notre haute
fonction publique dans ce cycle court
dans ce cycle politique au moment même
où les politiques publiques sont
confrontés à des choix qui sont des
choix de longue durée la transition
écologique et le communautarisme etc et
puis il ya un autre sujet de fond
l'administration c'est le bras séculier
de l'état
je le disais touché à l'administration
c'est toucher à l'état
derrière votre réforme il y à cette idée
faussement moderne est vraiment anglo
saxon d'un vaste système de dépouilles
mais c'est ignorer madame la ministre
c'est ignorer que le système américain à
des contrepoids solide que nous n'avons
pas c'est un système fédéral ou une
administration fédérale peut avoir une
orientation sans que dans tous les états
il y ait cette même orientation il ya un
autre contrepoids qui est la force du
parlement bien au dessus mes chers
collègues de la force de l'assemblée
nationale ou même ici du sénat ce sont
des contrepoids qui équilibre le système
de la dépouille et puis il ya quelque
chose si différent par rapport à notre
modèle français c'est l'état c'est que
nous l'état pressé de la nation notre
forme collective notre façon dhabi
tellement c'est l'état nation mais
l'état chez nous en france c'est pas le
cas en allemagne en italie ou ailleurs
c'est l'état qui fait la nation et si
vous cassez la confiance dans le peuple
du peuple français dans son
administration alors vous risquer
d'aggraver la crise démocratique je
voudrais terminer simplement pour vous
dire que je sais que souvent il y a eu
un reproche fait à l'ena qui est une
forme de consanguinité sociale problème
n'est pas dans cette école en
particulier il est dans l'école tout
court nous avons une école républicaine
malheureusement qu est une machine à
reproduire en france les inégalités
sociales il eût mieux valu voyez
réformer le système éducatif et non pas
par le bas nous en parlions pour les
études de médecine il ya quelques
instants dans les questions d'actualité
nous voulons nous évidemment la
méritocratie républicaine et enfin bien
entendu qu'il faut réformer l'état bien
entendu que l'organisation de l'état
n'est pas parfaite nous l'avons souvent
dit bien sûr trop souvent nous souffrons
de voir l'état se défaire de voir la
défiance des français vis à vis de leur
état mais cette défiance et concerne
beaucoup plus le monde politique nous
mêmes ou si je me mets dans le même
panier si j'ose dire madame que la haute
fonction publique qui sont aussi des
serviteurs de l'état alors je vais vous
dire je pense que vous avez tort de vous
défausser sur cet état profond
disait quelqu'un je pense que vous avez
tort de vous défausser sur un bouc
émissaire alors que la responsabilité
quand il ya un patron c'est toujours la
responsabilité du patron et pas de ses
collaborateurs je pense que bien sûr
qu'il fallait une réforme mais une autre
réforme qu'il eût fallu madame viser
beaucoup plus haut il aurait il eu fallu
ne pas se contenter d'une simple mise en
cause si facile si petit en somme de
cette fonction publique tiff est je
crois la spécificité de l'administration
française et qui est reconnu de façon
internationale je pense que cette remise
en cause a quelque chose à voir soit
avec la naïveté avec l'angélisme soit
avec le populisme avec le cynisme eh
bien nous ne céderons ni à l'un ni à
l'autre je pense que le relèvement le
redressement de l'état exige beaucoup
plus et je pense surtout que le
dévouement de nos fonctionnaires des
agents publics mérite beaucoup mieux
présidant la parole est à madame amélie
de montchalin ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique
madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame le rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
permet de voile permettez-moi d'abord de
vous remercier
de vous remercier de me donner
l'opportunité de défendre devant les
représentants des français cette réforme
l'état cette réforme de la haute
fonction publique qui est la plus
ambitieuse jamais conduite depuis 1945
et vous remercie parce qu'après tout les
fausses informations
la mauvaise foi le cynisme et les
mensonges que monsieur le président
retailleau vient de prononcer il me
semble qu'il est utile de clarifier de
sortir du brouillard simon rouillard et
bien
je suis d'ailleurs surpris ce monsieur
le président que issu d'une majorité qui
à de multiples reprises essayé de
réformer la haute fonction publique sans
y parvenir vous nous présentiez
aujourd'hui votre ambition d'avoir une
autre réforme mais qu'il n'ya
malheureusement aujourd'hui aucun
amendement dans la pièce à discuter à
débattre à confronter
transformer la france s'était
effectivement transformer l'état et
transformer l'état s'est aussi
transformé sa haute fonction publique
c'était un engagement du président la
république un engagement du programme
des macros en 2017 je tiens ici à le
citer parce qu'il est toujours
importante sera serré aux engagements
pris il disait le statut des
fonctionnaires ne sera pas remis en
cause mais il sera modernisée
décloisonner par un assouplissement du
système rigide décor nous mettrons en
particulier fin au système des grands
corps ne vous en déplaise donc cette
réforme était une promesse faite aux
français depuis 2010 est le gouvernement
avec le soutien de la majorité a conduit
avec détermination
cette réforme ambitieuse de la fonction
publique la loi de transformation la
fonction oblique d'août 2010 9 permet
vous savez même le rapporteur davantage
d'ouverture davantage de mots édité et
c'est bien cette loi majeurs d'août 2010
9 qui a ouvert la voie à la réforme de
la haute fonction publique que je suis
donc venu défendre devant vous
aujourd'hui alors permettez moi
peut-être pour commencer mais dans les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs de
replacer c'est très fin dans le temps
long le temps long que vous citiez
monsieur le président retailleau pour
que nous puissions en apprécié à la fois
la nécessité mais aussi la portée en
1945 notre pays sortait exemple d'une
guerre qui commandait de tout
reconstruire et le général de gaulle
engageait alors une refonte sans
précédent de nos institutions et de
notre administration
la refondation la haute fonction
publique était au coeur de ce projet de
refonte de l'état est ainsi furent créés
par ordonnance non sans résistance à
l'époque l'école nationale
d'administration et le corps des
administrateurs civils il était en effet
impérieux d'incarner la méritocratie
républicaine et de restaurer
l'efficacité de l'état projet auquel
vous savez michel debré a été associée a
été fortement associé puisqu'ils n'en
était l'architecte
aujourd'hui notre pays fait face à des
besoins nouveaux qui sont radicalement
différents de ceux de 1945 des
bouleversements technologiques un choc
climatique une crise sanitaire a besoin
réaffirmé de proximité et donc la france
du xxième siècle n'est plus celle de
1945 et l'état doit donc à nouveau
s'adapter en dépit de cela vous savez
l'état lui c'est régis dit fier et sa
haute fonction publique avec lui les
corporatismes se sont renforcés car
c'est bien des corporatismes que la
france est malade ils nourrissent donc
savons la bureaucratie ils nourrissent
mme le centralisme et nous avons décidé
avec cette majorité de nous y attaquer
combien de gouvernement avant nous ont
promis de s'appeler à cette réforme de
la haute fonction publique ils ont tous
échoué aucun ne l'a conduite jusqu'à son
terme je tenais à vous rappeler ici que
la suppression de les noms figuraient
déjà dans le programme commun de 1972
en 1995 le président chirac promettait
en parlant du classement de sortie de
l'ena de mettre fin je cite un système
de castes qui se cooptent son premier
ministre alain juppé annoncé à son tour
en 1997 qu'il fallait supprimer et qu'il
allait d'ailleurs supprimer les noms en
2008 une commission mandatée par le
président sarkozy promettait d'aboutir à
un nouveau mode de recrutement moderne
et transparent je le cite à nouveau pour
nous aux fonctionnaires et après des
juges c'est le sénat qui a fait au sac à
la suppression du classement de sortie
de l'ena françois hollande lui à son
tour après avoir demandé à madame
lebranchu de réformes et les grands
corps avait renoncé à toute réforme
suite à une pétition des élèves de
l'école et face à la levée de boucliers
des corporations alors près de trente
ans plus tard ménard est toujours là
avec son classement son système de
castes qui se cooptent comme le disait
président chirac et ses grands corps
alors voilà mesdames les sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs
contrairement majorité précédente que
vous avez soutenu ce gouvernement avec
la majorité qui est la sienne a enfin le
courage de mener cette réforme à son
terme et je tiens à rappeler j'y
reviendrai que c'est vous qui avez
habilité le gouvernement à conduire
cette réforme et ayant été habilité nous
avons donc pris nos responsabilités et
nous sommes devant vous cette réforme
nécessite de la détermination elle
n'hésite la conviction d'abord pour
parler aux français de ce que nous
faisons pour eux et ensuite également
pour parler aux fonctionnaires de ce que
nous faisons pour eux pour parler de
cette transformation profonde de l'état
que nous portons parce que cette
transformation elle repose sur un
constat simple elle répond à une
ambition claire dans la france de 2021
nos concitoyens ont des attentes
différentes de celles qu'il y a trente
ans voire même 70 ans il demande un état
de proximité un état efficace au service
de tous et j'en suis convaincue mais
nommée s'attriste messieurs les
sénateurs
la proximité
l'efficacité et l'égalité sont les trois
condition absolue de la restauration de
l'autorité de l'état
alors pour répondre à ces préoccupations
nous avons décidé de nous attaquer à la
racine des problèmes le premier sujet
c'est la formation nous devons changer
la formation initiale et la formation
continue pour que nos hauts
fonctionnaires comprennent mieux la
france dans son intimité dans sa
complexité pour que nous puissions
adapter nos politiques publiques pour
les différencier en fonction des
territoires nous devons faire en sorte
que tous nos fonctionnaires acquièrent
une culture commune pour que les
décisions ne soient plus prises en silo
et les locaux sont les premiers à s'en
plaindre et ils ont raison les
administrateurs de l'état demain les
directeurs d'hôpitaux les magistrats
judiciaires les commissaires de police
seront ainsi tous formés ensemble à ces
enjeux que sont la transition écologique
la laïcité les valeurs de la république
les défis numérique la lutte contre les
inégalités la pauvreté en résumé à la
différence de l'ena nous voulons une
école qui forme et pas une école qui
classe
ce sera la mission du futur institut
national du service public qui portera
ce tronc commun à 14 écoles de service
public dès 2022 qui renforcera le rôle
de la formation continue pour tous les
fonctionnaires pour tous léo fonctionnel
qui développera les liens avec le monde
académique et de la recherche et qui
participera au rayonnement européen et
international de la france
le deuxième sujet à racine que nous
voulons regarder et surtout réformée
après la formation c'est la gestion des
carrières il faut que nos fonctionnaires
occupent des fonctions opérationnelles
concrètes dans les territoires plus en
prise avec le quotidien de concitoyens
parce qu'avant de pouvoir juger contrôle
et inspecté diriger il faut avoir
administré il faut s'être confronté aux
réalités du terrain et ce n'est pas ces
dab semblait qui me contre à dire et pas
administrés nous ne comprenons pas
l'édiction de normes depuis une
administration centrale à paris nous
voyons au contraire des cadres
supérieurs davantage présent en
administrations déconcentrées pour avoir
un état territorial fort pour avoir une
action publique différencié pour avoir
des hauts fonctionnaires affectés sur
des postes opérationnels
je vous donne un exemple de ce que nous
avons fait cette année en 2021 nous
avons doublé le nombre de postes de
sortie de l'ena au ministère du travail
et au ministère des solidarités la santé
et nous avons divisé par deux le nombre
de sorties dans les grands corps après
la crise sanitaire alors que nous devons
faire réussir la relance est bien dans
ses ministères et dans leurs services
déconcentrés que nous avons besoin de
nos nouveaux hauts fonctionnaires et
vous parlez de confiance monsieur le
président retailleau pour que les phases
les français fassent confiance à l'état
il doit voir que l'état s'organise
s'adapte et se soucie des enjeux
prioritaires de son époque et s'il ya
bien deux ministères aujourd'hui qui ont
besoin d'être renforcées c'est bien et
on voit bien que c'est unanimement
défendable celui aujourd'hui du mr de
l'est scénarisé la santé et celui du
ministère du travail alors mesdames et
sénatrices et sénateurs ce qu'une bise
ou éclairent notre ambition est forte
cette réforme est désormais irréversible
mais il m'importe d'expliquer aux
français ce qui se joue aujourd'hui dans
cet hémicycle
permettez moi de vous dire que je
considère pour le moins étonnant
d'inscrire à l'ordre du jour votre
propre texte
afin de le rejeter purement et
simplement
inscrire la ratification d'une
ordonnance
pour ne pas la ratifier je dois dire que
c'est assez inédit dans les annales
parlementaires le gouvernement
s'était réjoui que le sénat se
saisissent de ses prérogatives
constitutionnelles de ces prêts
correctifs d'amendements de ses
prérogatives d'écriture de la loi et que
vous puissiez donc effectivement prend
l'initiative d'inscrits la ratification
ces tendances dans votre ordre du jour
nous étions prêts un débat important et
un débat qui est évidemment légitime
nous pensions que nous des batteries ion
d'un texte amendé qui nous auraient
permis d'entendre vos contre
propositions respectives et de connaître
votre vision de la haute fonction
publique de l'état demain mais
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun amendement en
débat il n'ya que devons nous en déduire
que devons-nous déduit
il n'ya pas d'amendement monsieur le
sénateur masson déposée par les co
signataires de la proposition de loi
commune que devons-nous déduire de ce
jeu politique que monsieur retailleau et
monsieur sur ne se sont peut-être pas
entendus pour déposer des amendements
communs peut-être devons-nous en déduire
que vous ne partagez pas la même vision
de l'état
peut-être devons-nous en déduire qu'il
n'y aurait donc pas lieu de réformer la
haute fonction publique que tout doit
rester en l'état que tout changement est
hors de propos ou alors vous dites il
faut une autre réforme mais quelles
réformes où sont les amendements où sont
les propositions je reconnais donc bien
là les conservatismes de tous bords et
je ne partage évidemment pas cette
vision je reconnais bien là une alliance
contre nature sur plusieurs banques sans
cohérence sans vision qui n'a pour objet
qu une opposition stérile et complète au
gouvernement les républicains les
socialistes les écologistes et les
centristes au fond semblent s'accorder
entre sur une seule chose il ne faudrait
rien changé voilà une belle alliance
cette politique politicienne ne me sens
pas à la hauteur des enjeux elle ne me
semble pas digne de cette haute
assemblée que je respecte et à laquelle
je me suis toujours soumise à toutes vos
questions il m'avait pourtant semblé
avoir lu et entendu des propositions
pour la fonction publique notamment à
droite de cet hémicycle dans votre
programme des républicains public ces
derniers jours il y est écrit en toutes
lettres monsieur prison retailleau que
vous comptez supprimer le statut de la
fonction publique et conserver les
grands corps projet digne a minima
d'incohérences ou d'injustices et puis
sur la gauche je dois dire que là je
n'ai entendu aucun projet alors avant de
conclure mais les sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs
il m'appartient de lever un malentendu
j'ai entendu dire que cette réforme
n'aurait pas été concertés qu'elle
aurait été fomenté dans le secret des
dieux qu'elles seraient déconnectés des
attentes de nos concitoyens et de nos
fonctionnaires je souhaite ici rétablir
la vérité d'abord cette réforme je ne
suis pas devant vous parce que la
constitution m'y autorise je suis devant
vous parce que vous m'avez autorisés à
être devant vous aujourd'hui parce que
c'est bien ici au sénat que l'article 59
a été amendée qu'il a été enrichie qu'il
a été voté que vous l'avez validé par la
commission mixte paritaire de la loi de
transformation de la fonction publique
dont madame di folco été le rapporteur
et si je suis devant vous c'est bien
parce que vous lui avez autorisé c'est
le principe d'une ordonnance nous ne
faisons pas la loi en cachette nous la
faisons parce que vous nous autoriser à
la faire et c'est donc bien un texte
issu d'une cmp conclusif qui est donc
s'inscrit évidemment dans un cadre
constitutionnel mais qui respecte par
définition le parlement par ailleurs en
tant que tel sur l' ordonnance depuis ma
prise de fonction a même des avants dans
le cas du rapport qui avait été commandé
à monsieur thiriez frédéric thiriez que
vous avez rencontré l'ensemble des
parties prenantes ont été consultés il y
avait des instances formelle des
instances obligatoire des tables rondes
avec les as raison des différents corps
personne n'a été laissée à l'écart de
cette réforme je dis bien personne et
surtout pas les hauts fonctionnaires eux
mêmes puisque ils ont été formellement
interrogé au cours d'une consultation
inédite de plusieurs semaines à laquelle
plus de 7300 d'entre eux ont répondu
exercice absolument inédit que j'ai tenu
à mener pour nous assurer de la
cohérence des décisions que nous prenons
avec leurs attentes et d'ailleurs qui
pas permis de rappeler combien leur
attachement au service public à ces
valeurs est important et combien ils
attendaient précisément que nous
prenions les mesures que nous prenons
pour les accompagner dans leur carrière
dans leur formation dans l'eure mobilité
dans l'accompagnement leur vie
personnelle et professionnelle autant
d'éléments que cette perte que cette
récente permettent deux biens auxquels
on nous répondons nous répondons aussi
un enjeu d'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes un enjeu majeur de cette
réforme va permettre de faire avancer je
souhaite donc ici remercier très
sincèrement
l'ensemble des hauts fonctionnaires et
des parties prenantes qui ont permis
cette réforme et puis je voudrais donc
conclure en un mot l'esprit de cette
réforme de cette ordonnance que vous
soumettez aujourd'hui à une ratification
express de votre assemblée c'est ce que
nous faisons je viens d'expliquer mais
le gouvernement ne reculera donc pas
devant des réflexes corporatistes qui
sont toujours bruyant mais qui ne sont
généralement jamais réellement
représentatifs et qui nous savons se
dresse dès qu'ils sont menacés je
regrette profondément que nous ne
puissions pas débattre aujourd'hui
projet contre projet je regrette le
choix qui était le vôtre de consacrer ce
temps parlementaire précieux un débat
par définition stérile qui se résume à
une opposition de principe
êtes vous pouvez être assuré de la
détermination qui est la mienne sous
l'autorité du président la république et
du premier ministre à mener à bien cette
réforme majeure est indispensable cette
réforme se poursuivra coûte que coûte
car en effet ce débat même limité et
inabouti de votre fête renforce
profondément notre conviction que cette
réforme est plus que jamais nécessaire
contre les corporatismes contre les
immobilismes pour les agents publics
pour l'état pour la france et pour les
français c'est la raison pour laquelle
je donnerai donc bien sûr un avis
favorable à cette proposition de loi qui
propose la ratification d'une ordonnance
qui pose les jalons de la réforme de
notre eau fonction publique la plus
ambitieuse depuis 1945 je vous remercie
je voulais vous dire madame la ministre
que depuis le début vous dit quelque
chose de faux vous dites que vous faites
une réforme dans votre texte il n'y a
pas de réforme
votre texte c'est une
construction du texte de 1945 vous
prenez tous les articles et vous les
sabots lycée et ainsi vous mettez à mal
une construction républicaine qui nous
réunit tous vous comprenez cela c'est
très important c'est de dire que vous
faites une réforme vous déconstruisent
et ce qui a été construit depuis la
résistance avec le général de gaulle et
michel devrait bien d'autres vous le
savez pourquoi ne le dites vous pas
puisque vous le savez aussi bien que moi
vous comprenez alors les corps
d'inspection
il y en aura plus et l'indépendance ces
inspecteurs généraux par rapport il
compris à l'égard du ministre ils ont le
devoir de lui dire la vérité
ce sera mis à mal
quant au préfet ça existe le corps des
préfets moi ça fait 40 ans que je
travaille avec des vrais faits et j'ai
une haute estime pour eux vous aurez
demain des préfet intermittents
intérimaire
fonctionnarisé
contractualisés je vois bien ce que
c'est c'est un système qui met en cause
toute une cohérence républicaine qui
alors de la décentralisation est
nécessaire parce que les deux sont
nécessaires moi je suis brute force
décentralisation et un pouvoir de l'état
fort solide ça veut pas dire qu'il soit
omnipotent mais qu'il fasse avec
cohérence ce qu'il a à faire madame la
ministre vous ne faites pas de réforme
vous déconstruisent et le texte de 45
merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre monsieur président de
la commission des lois madame le
rapporteur et mes chers collègues
vous me permettrait d'avoir madame le
ministre de vous dire que nous avons
modérément goûté le ton et le contenu
des propos que vous avez tenus à l'égard
du sénat dans le figaro de ce matin je
n'ai pas non plus beaucoup apprécié la
manière très polémique quand vous avez
abordé le débat
je souhaite pour ma part que nous nous
en tenons au fond et je crois qu'il ya
matière à discuter
là dessus toutefois je vais vous dire
deux choses pour répondre les arguments
que vous avez utilisé d'abord je croyais
que la recherche de terrains d'entente
entre la droite et la gauche et est au
fondement même du maquereau nisme et par
conséquent je ne vois pas ce qui vous
choque du fait que plusieurs présidents
de groupe et membre de groupes
différents ce soit associé pour obtenir
l'inscription de votre ordonnance à
l'ordre du jour du sénat car justement
cette inscription à l'ordre du jour vous
vous ne l'aviez pas obtenu vue et vous
devriez être satisfaite après tout parce
que la consécration législative de votre
travail est dans l'ordre de la
constitution et c'est une légitimation
que vous ne pouvez pas avoir par le
simple fait d'une signature des membres
de l'exécutif et par conséquent je crois
qu'il y a là un vin débat je voulais
l'évacuer dès le début de haut
l'intervention
à vous écouter d'ailleurs je suis un peu
surpris de cela aussi nous n'aurions pas
d'autre option que tu as trouvé votre
texte de l'amender enfin dans le débat
parlementaire il arrive aussi et je
souhaite que ce soit le moins souvent
possible qu'on rejette un texte parce
que on le juge non amendables on refuse
de s'inscrire dans les dispositions
qu'il prévoit et c'est le cas avec votre
ordonnance je comprends que cela vous
contrarie mais c'est la nature même du
débat démocratique d'échanger des
convictions les nôtres sont différentes
des vôtres admettez-le s'il vous plaît
je voudrais vous dire que nous avons
avec votre ordonnance c'est la haute
fonction publique de
difficultés l'unl une touche au
fonctionnement de la démocratie
parlementaire dans le respect de la
lettre et de l'esprit de la constitution
et l'autre touche au fonctionnement de
l'état dans le respect de nos traditions
républicaines avec pour seul impératif
mais je sais que vous le partagez je
n'attaque pas votre bonne foi
la qualité du service public nous
empruntons des chemins différents pour
atteindre ce deuxième objectif
ces deux difficultés sont graves et nous
conduisent à rejeter votre ordonnance en
souhaitant que l'assemblée nationale en
débattent à son tour et cela dépend
naturellement de vous mais aussi des
groupes qui composent l'assemblée la
notion nationale alors la difficulté du
point de vue du respect du parlement en
démocratie elle tient à deux choses
d'abord il ya bu une ordonnance ça je
crois que c'est vraiment incontestable
les chiffres en attestent j'y reviendrai
dans un astre et deuxièmement il y as
carence de ratification ça fait quand
même beaucoup et vous devez comprendre
que nous représentants de la nation en
soyons extrêmement tirith et l'abus
d'hormones ans oui les ordonnances de
l'article 38 historiquement
constitutionnellement c'est quelque
chose qui est tout à fait essentiel et
moi je ne conteste pas l'article 38 de
la constitution mais que dit il il dit
que le gouvernement peut nous demander
de l'habilité à légiférer par
ordonnances pour son programme attend le
programme c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas précisément défini dans la
constitution mais le seul endroit où on
reparle de programme c'est l'article 49
de la constitution le premier ministre
engage la responsabilité de son
gouvernement sur son programme et vous
voyez le niveau auquel se situe le
pouvoir d'habilitation du parlement il
s'agit de choses essentielles au fil des
années et pas seulement d'ailleurs sous
cette mandature on a vu se dégrader le
niveau d'exigence des lois
d'habilitation par rapport à la
politique générale du gouvernement mais
je ne conteste pas après tout que la
réforme de la haute fonction publique de
l'état puissent faire l'objet
d'ordonnancés quand elle est au coeur du
programme du gouvernement j'observe
simplement que le premier ministre au
moment où il a fait sa déclaration de
politique générale a purement et
simplement oublié de mentionner cet
aspect de son programme donc c'est pas
dans le programme ça vous empêche pas
d'agir évidemment alors lab une
ordonnance il se caractérise par la
banalisation du recours aux ordonnances
14 par an entre 1984 et 2007 30 entre
2007 et 2012 54 entre 2012 et 2017
64 parrot depuis 2010 est il est vrai
que vous avez des excuses du coc vide et
je veux bien donc défalquer les
ordonnances lié à l'urgence sanitaire
mais sans que ce soit seulement du fait
de ce gouvernement il y a abu
d'ordonnancé si nous sommes ici à propos
de votre ordonnance tellement en colère
c'est aussi pour signifier au
gouvernement qu'il est en vous et nous
de donner un coup d'arrêt à cette
pratique quand elle était abusivement
utilisée
alors le pire c'est qu'on pourrait
penser que puisqu'on fait des
ordonnances ont fait moins de loi
ce serait logique et bien c'est le
contraire qui se produit plus on fait de
lois plus on fait aussi dans 90 et on
voit cette saturation de l'action
publique par la loi tout se passe comme
si la fin ultime de toute action du
gouvernement était de légiférer et notre
pays dans une confusion croissante
là aussi je vous épargne les chiffres je
les ai noté je les tiens à votre
disposition vous les connaissez
c'est de très mauvaises pratiques
les français n'y comprennent plus rien
leur entreprise leur administration leur
association leur collectivité n'y
comprennent plus rien il est temps
d'arrêter cette inflation législative
dans laquelle contribuent les
ordonnances quant aux ratifications
alors là vous êtes vraiment ce
gouvernement très mauvais élève
52% de texte ratifié sous le quinquennat
du président sarkozy 42% sous le
quinquennat du président hollande est
pour les quatre premières années du
quinquennat du président macron 31% on
passe de la moitié à moins du tiers ça
n'est pas de correct il faut à un moment
que la lame soit donné et qu'on cesse de
multiplier les ordonnances d'une part et
de diviser le nombre de ratifications
comme nous le voyons aujourd'hui alors
maintenant votre réforme votre réforme
je ne la couche pas je ne considère pas
que rebaptisé et nayan sp et y adjoindre
les formations pour d'autres catégories
de fonds de fonctionnaires soit un réel
progrès je ne vois pas au moment où nous
parlons de
l'amélioration de la prise en compte des
métiers pourquoi il faudrait fondre dans
un grand magma toutes les formations des
hauts fonctionnaires vous avez fragilité
fragilise et non pas des corps mais des
institutions constitutionnelles en
modifiant les modalités du recrutement
pour les fondée non pas sur le mérite
intellectuel mais sur la pratique
administrative sachez que la cour des
comptes et au conseil d'état les
qualités opérationnelles ne sont pas les
premières qui sont nécessaires pour
réussir à maîtriser les outils les
concepts intellectuels qui sont
appliquées dans ces institutions
constitutionnelles quant à
l'interministérialité le corps des
administrateurs civils
exprime cette interministériel it et que
voulez vous rendre de plus
interministériel peut-être que la
pratique a été mauvaise mais selon la
corriger la pratique je crois que nous y
parviendrons facilement s'il y a une
volonté politique durable je voudrais
vous signaler enfin que votre ordonnance
et c'est pas son moindre défaut dans ses
premiers articles relève purement et
simplement
de l'instruction du premier ministre
voilà une ordonnance qui traitent de
sujets de circulaire oui il faut une
gestion prévisionnelle des emplois ça
n'a pas à figurer dans une ordonnance
oui il faut une gestion des ressources
humaines efficace ça n'a pas à figurer
dans une ordonnance il a quatre articles
les quatre premiers articles de notre
ordonnance qui vraiment n'ont pas leur
place dans un texte législatif et voilà
pourquoi nous ne pouvons pas approuver
cette ordonnance et je remercie les
auteurs de la proposition de loi de
ratification d'avoir trouvé enfin le
moyen qu'on en débatte au sénat merci
monsieur le questeur
la parole est à madame vraiment de
penser mange pour cinq minutes chers
collègues
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mais chaque
connaît le gouvernement a pris la
regrettable habitude de course écouter
le parlement ont les différents par
ordonnance dans des proportions sans
commune mesure avec ce que la vème
république avait connu jusqu'à la cela
vient d'être très bien démontré votre
absence de considération pour le pouvoir
législatif ne semble pas connaître de
limites nous nous retrouvons donc dans
la position invraisemblable il est vrai
de nous auto saisir de la ratification
de vos ordonnances pour provoquer le
débat parlementaire
s'agissant du sujet qui nous occupe la
réforme de la haute fonction publique
rien absolument rien ne justifiait le
recours à l'ordonnancé dont beaucoup
d'articles ni l'urgence totalement
absente ni la technicité du sujet
transformer la haute administration pour
l'adapter aux enjeux du 21e siècle
réforme lna les grands corps cela
nécessitait un débat politique digne de
ce nom devant la représentation
nationale madame la ministre ne fait pas
semblant de ne pas comprendre donc notre
démarche commune d'aujourd'hui il y
avait donc beaucoup à dire c'est nous
retrouvions la loi de transformation de
la fonction publique de juin 2019 qui
affaiblissait le statut de fonctionnaire
et ouvrait grande la porte des emplois
publics à des contractuels recrutés hors
concours souvent dans des conditions
précaires cette ordonnance qui en émane
n'est pas à rejeter en bloc la réforme
de l'ena transformer en institut
national du service public étaient
nécessaires l'intégration systématique
des grands corps d'état pour les élèves
arrivés en tête du classement de sortie
était une pratique d'un autre temps un
symbole fort de la déconnexion
croissante entre les élites politico
administratives et la population a
fortiori dans notre état jacobins où ces
administrations sont concentrées dans la
capitale
a contrario rendre obligatoire pour les
futurs diplômés d'exercer cinq années
dans les services déconcentrés de l'état
nous semble une très bonne chose la
création d'un corps unique des
administrateurs de l'état laisse
également espérer plus de mobilité des
hauts fonctionnaires au sein de la
sphère publique et des carrières plus
cantonner à un seul ministère choisit
pour 40 ans dès la sortie de l'ena
inclure dans la formation des
administrateurs des modules relatifs à
la transition écologique à la
transformation numérique de nos
économies ou encore aux enjeux de la
pauvreté relève du bon sens enfin nerio
nous nous n'avons néanmoins pas beaucoup
d'illusions sur les évolutions du
contenu pédagogique de l'école dans une
logique plus les néo libérale toujours
prégnante on continuera à y apprendre
très certainement que la dépense
publique est un problème et
l'intervention publique dans le secteur
économique une hérésie nous sommes
circonspects sur la suppression du corps
des préfets nous craignons qu'ils nous
beaucoup trop les administrations
préfectorale à des profils venus du
privé de ce fait nous nous inquiétons de
l'affaiblissement du sens de service du
service public et de l'intérêt général
chez les serviteurs de l'état pour ne
pas dire de la multiplication
quelquefois des conflits d'intérêts et
c'est bien là que le bât blesse est que
nous nous sommes dans l'incapacité de
faire confiant de vous faire confiance
votre philosophie exprimée par la loi de
2010 d'un fait l'ouverture de la
fonction publique la multiplication des
allers-retours prend le public et le
privé nous nous opposons fermement au
pantouflage des conservateurs de l'état
or tout laisse à penser que cette
ordonnance loin de lutter contre ce
phénomène délétère va le favoriser
d'autant plus que ce texte est très
général est que l'essentiel des
dispositions est renvoyé au règlement
l'absence du débat parlementaire est ici
totalement préjudiciable
il aurait permis d'encadrer le travail
réglementaire y compris du gouvernement
pour toutes ces raisons
nous voterons contre la ratification de
cette ordonnance et nous espérons que
l'exécutif reviendra devant le parlement
pour présenter une ambitieuse réforme de
la haute autorité de la haute fonction
publique plus largement demandons
l'organisation d'un débat annuel au
parlement sur la gestion des ressources
humaines de l'état cela doit faire
partie de notre mission de contrôle pour
conclure il ya quinze jours le collectif
nos services publics publié une enquête
révélant que 80 % des agents interrogés
se déclaraient confronté un sentiment
d'absurdité dans l'exercice de leur
travail
c'est un des éléments quelquefois de la
souffrance au travail l'heure est donc
grave il convient d'en tenir compte dans
nos restaurants je vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est à madame
cécile kerman pour le groupe crc
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues tout
d'abord une remarque effectivement sur
la forme mais cela a été fait par de
nombreux collègues avant moins inquiets
la multiplication du recours aux
ordonnances qui n'est pas nouvelle mais
qui s'est fortement accélérée depuis le
début de ce quinquennat qui se termine
dans quelques mois maintenant
devrais je rappeler que la force de
l'ordonnancé certainement son
utilisation avec parcimonie et que à
force d'avoir trop recours aux
ordonnances de fait l'on retire la
capacité au parlement à pouvoir faire la
loi mais qui plus est se rajoute à cela
la jurisprudence qui a été également
déjà évoqué et qui fait que demain il
sera possible que cette ordonnance
devienne loi j'aurais envie de le dire
ainsi sans même repasser devant le
parlement on pourrait d'ailleurs
s'interroger sur l'esprit même de ceux
qui a fondé notre république et
finalement qui a animé les grands temps
révolutionnaire de notre histoire qui
ont toujours été guidée par une volonté
de renforcer la séparation des pouvoirs
plutôt qu'au contraire de la réduire sur
le fond et sur la question de la réforme
de la haute fonction publique je croix
madame la ministre qu'il ne faut pas
nous y trompez oui il y a inévitablement
besoin aujourd'hui d'une réforme de la
haute fonction publique il y a besoin
d'une réforme pour en garantir son
indépendance
pour en garantir sa capacité n'ont pas à
décider à la place des élus des
ministres combien de fois avons nous
entendu
deux ministres ici même ou plus dans les
couloirs ou dans la presse expliquer que
certains hauts fonctionnaires
du ministère de la finance décidés à
leur place
et donc l'objectif est au contraire
d'assurer cette capacité à aider à
conseiller à éclairer à donner de la
perspective sur un temps inévitablement
mais cela a déjà été dit beaucoup plus
long que celui d'un mandat quelle que
soit cette durée
vous avez
également certainement raison dans un
constat qui serait d'ailleurs partagé
ici sur des dérives aujourd'hui de sa
haute fonction publique ce d'état et
dans sa formation mais attention il ne
faudrait pas remplacer un autre soit par
un autre entre soins il ne faudrait pas
demain arriver finalement à avoir une
autre fonction publique d'état qui soit
encore plus dépendante du pouvoir en
place et qui finalement par d'autres
réseaux face que un entre soi certes
social aujourd'hui soir pour remplacer
par un autre soit de connaissance et
donc il y à bien un véritable enjeu
d'avoir une réflexion sur comment
toujours mieux et plus fort mais ces
hauts fonctionnaires assurer l'égalité
républicaine et je veux le redire ici ce
n'est pas en supprimant les nains que
l'on règle cette question c'est au
contraire mais faudrait un débat sur
l'ensemble de la politique éducative
dans notre pays en redonnant toute sa
place à l'école depuis le début en
assurant et en garantissant la réussite
de tous et pas simplement en clamant
l'égalité des chances que nous
relèverons ce défi n'oublions pas tout
de même que l'ena a été redéfinie au
sortir de la guerre pour remplacer
d'administration qui était compromise
avec le régime de vichy et que donc
cette question de l'indépendance au
pouvoir est tout de même un phénomène
important que l'on ne peut pas
simplement balayés et dont l'objectif
était de faire de ce fonctionnaire
former un homme et non pas un simple
rouage de l'administration or ce que
vous nous proposez ne répond en rien à
ce défi tout aux temps modernes
aujourd'hui en ce début du 21e siècle
qu'il l'était au lendemain de la seconde
guerre mondiale alors bien évidemment la
question n'est pas de rester dans
l'existant mais nous avons je crois
encore le droit en démocratie de pouvoir
nous opposer à la réforme qui est la
vôtre ce que madame la ministre la
démocratie ce n'est pas changer pour
changer la démocratie c'est pouvoir
permettre de débattre et c'est sur cela
que nous retrouvons c'est pouvoir
permettre de nous affronter et de poser
des propositions différentes et c'est
pour cela que nous nous retrouvons est
donc bien évidemment il peut ya un
accord pour débattre ou nous opposer à
ce texte ce qui ne veut pas dire que
nous aurons pizze tous sur tous les
bancs les mêmes propositions
alternatives et je terminerai juste en
une seconde vous avez utilisé les femmes
qui ne seraient pas les miennes mais je
pense que le naufrage politique n'est
pas celui du sénat aujourd'hui toute
réforme
peut-être rejoignent aucune réforme qui
est irréversible et si votre objectif
est effectivement ni ans le débat entre
la gauche et à droite de vous retrouver
face à un chroniqueur qui anime qui est
plus animé par la haine des autres sur
l'amour de faire de la république je
pense que ce n'est pas là la réussite
d'un quinquennat merci charles collet la
parole est un monsieur hervé marseille
pour le groupe union centriste mais seul
président
monsieur le président madame par madame
la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
lors de son intervention à l'occasion de
la convention managériale de l'état le 8
avril dernier le président de la
république a précisé les contours d'une
réforme de la haute fonction publique et
cédant aux exigences de l'instant
annoncé à cette occasion la suppression
de l'ena rebaptisé institut national du
service public
l'ordonnancé du 2 juin 2010 9 portant
réforme de l'encadrement supérieur de la
fonction publique d'état que la présente
ppl vise à ratifier concrétise
l'engagement présidentiel de réformes et
la haute fonction publique outre la
suppression de l'ena l'ordonnant
supprime aussi les grands corps d'état
elle privilégie les missions
opérationnelles pour les premiers
emplois créés des évaluations régulières
des pratiques professionnelles et
valorise la prise de risque
la loi de transformation de la fonction
publique du 6 août 2019 avec habilité le
gouvernement à légiférer par ordonnance
dans le cadre de l'article 38 de la
constitution
or si l'article 38 dispose qu'un projet
de loi de ratification doit être déposé
devant le parlement ils n'auront pas
obligatoire l'examen du projet de loi en
l'espèce le gouvernement a bien déposé
un projet de loi de ratification à
l'assemblée le 29 juillet 2021 toutefois
depuis cette date rien n'indique que le
gouvernement ait une intention
d'inscrire ce texte à l'ordre du jour en
refusant d'inscrire un tel texte à
l'ordre du jour le gouvernement esquive
le débat parlementaire sur une réforme
pourtant substantielle de
l'administration en se saisissant lui
même de la question le sénat est à
l'origine de la première discussion au
parlement d'une proposition de loi de
ratification d'une ordonnance une
initiative c'est vrai nouvelle rare qui
dépasse les clivages politiques
cela a déjà été rappelées puisque cette
ppl est co signé par quatre présidents
de groupe je regrette pour ma part aussi
comme l'a fait le président pas tout à
l'heure la polémique qui a pu exister
sur un sujet ma foi qui ne méritait pas
avant d'évoquer spécifiquement l'
ordonnance du 2 juin 2021 le débat de
cet après midi nous offre l'occasion
d'évoquer plus généralement usage des
ordonnances par le gouvernement de clips
plusieurs mois les chiffres sont très
claires il n'y a jamais eu autant de
redonnant cela a été dit que pendant ce
quinquennat
303 ordonnance ou 20 septembre soit +46
% par rapport à la période 2012 2017
évidemment il ya eu la crise sanitaire
elle justifie une partie de ses textes
mais cette tendance avait largement
débuté avant la crise et cela a été
démontré par les orateurs précédents ce
recours excessif aux ordonnances vient
d'ailleurs d'être récemment dénoncé dans
l'étude annuelle du conseil d'état le
conseil indique je cite que malgré l'
utilité indéniable des ordonnances en
période de crise une utilisation massive
accentue fortement le déséquilibre
institutionnel au profit du pouvoir
exécutif autrement dit la victime est
toujours la même le parlement pour ne
rien arranger une récente décision du
conseil constitutionnel vient jeter le
trouble sur cette question en effet dans
deux décisions de mai juillet 2021 le
conseil a reconnu aux ordonnances du
gouvernement n'ont ratifié par le
parlement une valeur législative
ce qui n'est pas sans fragiliser le
principe constitutionnel selon lequel la
loi expression de la volonté générale ne
peut naître que de la délibération
publique plus spécifiquement je rappelle
que l'article 38 exige que les
ordonnances soit ratifiée de manière
express avec les décision précitée du
conseil certains ont évoqué même la
création d'une législation par voix
gouvernementale
face à cela que peut faire le sénat
notre haute assemblée depuis longtemps
mobilisés sur ces questions nous avons
récemment encore était force de
proposition puisque notre règlement
vient justement d'intégrer des outils
afin d'opérer un contrôle plus étroit de
la législation délégué c'est à dire des
ordonnances de l'article 38 nous avons
ainsi ajouter le suivi des ordonnances
aux missions des différentes commissions
permanentes du sénat et renforcer son
information sur les intentions du
gouvernement quant à leur publication et
leur ratification voilà pour la forme
cette proposition de loi ouvre les
conditions d'un vrai débat sur
l'opportunité et l'intérêt d'une telle
réforme je rappelle en préambule que oui
c'est vrai en 2019 le sénat n'a pas émis
d'objection à l'habilitation à faire
cette réforme par voie d'ordonnancé
c'est un fait mais comme vous le savez
mes chers collègues une habilitation ce
n'est pas un blanc seing si le
gouvernement nous avait donné des
orientations en 2019 tout n'était pas
sur la table un exemple parmi d'autres
un des plus importants un des plus
médiatiques la suppression de l'ena
pourquoi supprimer l'ena pour la
remplacer par une autre école qui ne
change ni ses modalités d'accès ni son
classement de sortie ni même les
épreuves du concours externe parler de
suppression est d'ailleurs une
supercherie puisqu'en fait rien n'a été
supprimé on veut nous faire croire qu'on
a cassé le moule de cette fameuse
technocratie qui serait la cause de tous
nos maux pourquoi supprimer les grands
corps de l'état au refuge d'excellence
et de méritocratie qui rendait la haute
fonction publique attractive
le remplacement des grands corps par un
large encore qu'on a interministériel la
gestion centralisée nous garantit t-il
une meilleure fonction publique certains
crient au contraire cela a été dit une
politisation des fonctionnaires
notamment au niveau des ambassadeurs et
des préfets pendant la crise sanitaire
on a célébré tous les matins presque
tous les matins les vertus du couple
maire préfet piliers de l'état unitaire
décentralisé
pourquoi aujourd'hui déconstruire un
symbole de la république autour duquel
s'est forgée damnation la
fonctionnalisation des postes de préfets
de départements et de régions c'est
introduire demain le doute sur la
qualité des nominations non plus
seulement fondé sur le mérite une
expérience mais motivé peut-être parfois
par la faveur politique vous l'aurez
compris mes chers collègues nous avons
avec les membres de mon groupe une
double interrogation une déception sur
la forme car le gouvernement a voulu
échapper au débat parlementaire sur
cette réforme et nous le regrettons sur
le fond car le gouvernement n'a pas
résisté à quelques mesures qui ne sont
pas véritablement à la hauteur des
enjeux c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous ne prendrons pas part au vote la
commission n'ayant pas élaboré de textes
nous passant la discussion de l'article
unique de la proposition de loi initiale
et avant d'examiner les amendements je
suis saisi d'une demande de parole de
madame lienemann chers collègues oui
chers collègues vous excuserez ma voix
un peu éraillée qui méritera d'être
longue du coup premier point madame la
ministre vous demandez une vision baye
fall un projet de loi parce que la haute
fonction publique et son avenir exige
une loi globale qui soit l'occasion de
clarifier de débattre et de rendre
lisible aux français ce qu'ils ont fait
ils n'ont rien compris à votre histoire
rien compris quand aux mutations c'est
hyper technique est par ailleurs dans
bien des cas c'est dangereux et ça c'est
mon point de vue et vous nous expliquer
maintenant que la l'ordonnancé n'est
qu'à faire des contre propositions
le problème de l'ordonnancé déjà en soi
chers collègues moi je veux jamais sauf
des cas rarissimes des ordonnances le
parlement de se faire respecter faut
dire non bon on l'a pas fait mais c'est
encore plus grave maintenant parce que
avec le principe de non ratification
fait loi qui est finalement ce qu'elle
validait on est totalement déposséder
même de la modification de ce qu'elle
dans lordonnance donc j'approuve la
démarche qui vise à dire faut mettre les
pieds dans le plat on peut pas accepter
cette méthode mais la méthode est
révélatrice du contenu
parce que la route fonction publique moi
je suis pour une haute fonction publique
indépendante neutre n'est pas un état
dans l'état et pour ce soit pas l'état
dans l'état faut qu'elle soit ni
soumises de manière abusive au pouvoir
du de l'exécutif et surtout pas
ignorante de l'importance du parlement
dans l'élaboration de la pensée des
solutions et des réflexions comme
d'ailleurs des partenaires sociaux et
d'autres opérateurs or justement plus
notre système institutionnel
dévalorise le parlement plus votre
culture du spoil system pour les hauts
fonctionnaires fonctionne moi ils sont
respiration avec la réalité de ce pays -
ils sont porteurs dans la durée de toute
cette complexité autres la nécessité
d'être efficace de suivre la ligne
politique du gouvernement mais aussi de
prendre en compte la script sion dans le
temps de ce qu'est l'état l'état n'est
pas seulement un instrument au pouvoir
du gouvernement
troisième point que je veux dire c'est
que le sujet majeur il n'a pas traité
l'indépendance des hauts fonctionnaires
par rapport aux lobbys et par rapport
aux puissances économiques
j'ai fait le regard des hauts
fonctionnaires contre été la loi de
séparation bancaire
70% notre travail dans les grandes
banques il faut conclure dans les
voyages ce sujet qu'est centrale n'est
jamais très bien sûr votre formation de
vos propositions
la parole est à monsieur sueur
madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je voulais vous dire madame la ministre
que depuis le début vous dit quelque
chose de faux vous dites que vous faites
une réforme dans votre texte il n'y a
pas de réforme
votre texte c'est une déconstruction du
texte de 1945 vous prenez tous les
articles et vous les sabots lycée et
ainsi vous mettez à mal une construction
républicaine qui nous réunit tous vous
comprenez cela c'est très important
c'est c'est de dire que vous faites une
réforme vous déconstruisent et ce qui a
été construit depuis la résistance avec
le général de gaulle et michel devrait
bien d'autres vous le savez pourquoi ne
le dites vous pas puisque vous le savez
aussi bien que moi vous comprenez alors
les corps d'inspection
il y en aura plus et l'indépendance ces
inspecteurs généraux par rapport il
compris à l'égard du ministre ils ont le
devoir de lui dire la vérité
ce sera mis à mal quant au préfet ça
existe le corps des préfets moi ça fait
40 ans que je travaille avec des préfets
et j'ai une haute estime pour eux vous
aurez demain des préfets intermittents
intérimaire
fonctionnarisé
contractualisés je vois bien ce que
c'est
c'est un système qui met en cause toute
une cohérence républicaine qui alors de
la décentralisation est nécessaire parce
que les deux sont nécessaires moi je
suis pour une forte décentralisation
et un pouvoir de l'état fort solide ça
veut pas dire qu'il soit omnipotent mais
qu'il fasse avec cohérence ce qu'il a à
faire
madame la mini
ils forment vous déconstruisent et le
texte de 45 merci chers collègues merci
monsieur le questeur alors nous passons
à l'amendement numéro 2 monsieur masson
vous deviez être absent moment où ils
ont été défendent et posez vous allez
récupérer immédiatement
cet amendement
rentrer dans ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure bon dans cette affaire nous
sommes pour nous sommes contre la
réforme bon j'ai entendu des collègues
qui soutenait la réforme d'autres qui
disent qu'on n'est pas d'accord bon on
ne peut pas se quitter on décide en rien
bon cet amendement que je propose numéro
2 est bien supprime la réforme est donc
s'il est particulièrement radical dans
sa rédaction puisque donc on abroge en
redonnant si on demandera en face qui
revient à demander au gouvernement de
reprendre à zéro la réforme de gérer
correctement la situation
donc c'est toute la logique de ceux qui
ont exprimé ou où on souhaitait que
cette réforme ont considéré que cette
réforme n'était pas bonne et donc on
peut pas rester comme ça faire débat on
fait un débat pour faire un débat alors
si c'est faire un débat pour faire un
débat il ya qu à rester à la maison ça
sert à rien tout le monde s'en moque le
gouvernement s'en moque bon ce qu'il
faut c'est voter c'est dire on est pour
ou on est contre la réforme est
l'intérêt de cet abonnement permet à
ceux qui le souhaitent de dire qu'ils
sont contre la réforme et que donc ils
rejettent le système parce que sinon on
va se quitter on aura discuté pendant
deux heures pour rien du tout et ça
continuera comme avant merci amis de la
commission madame le rapporteur oui
merci madame la présidente écoutez
monsieur masson ce quoi vous allez au
delà de ce que vous venez de dire dans
votre amendement numéro 2 puisque vous
non seulement vous demander l'abrogation
delà de la présente
ordonnance mais vous demandez aussi
l'abrogation de la loi de transformation
de la fonction publique j'allais dire
vous êtes hors sujet et il est hors de
question de toucher à cette loi de
transformation de la fonction publique
donc la commission émet un avis
défavorable
merci madame le rapporteur madame la
ministre
merci madame la présidente je crois
quand même la rapporteure cet amendement
va bien au delà du sujet du jour et je
crois que la réforme qui a été votée en
août 2019 et promu liés sur la
transformation la fonction publique est
porteuse de nombreuses avancées qui ont
fait l'objet de beaucoup de débats et
que ce serait aller au delà des débats
du jour donc je suis défavorable je vous
remercie je vais mettre au monsieur
masson pour explication de vote
de toute manière
je enfin pour ma part j'ai voté fin je
suis content l'ordonnancé j'ai pas voté
la loi la loi en question mais
indépendamment de sa rassurez vous
madame la la la rapporteuse ou le
rapporteur le nom mais je sais pas
comment enfin selon les personnes
à ce niveau là c'est s'il faut qu'elle
était un petit il faut utiliser non ce
que je vais dire c'est c'est qu'ensuite
ensuite j'ai des amendements aussi vous
avez pu le remarquer qui supprime toutes
et tous les articles de l'ordonance
rassurez vous j'ai de la suite dans les
idées bon j'ai fait un prix de gros au
départ mais ensuite j'ai les amendements
de repli
alors je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement numéro 2 qui a reçu deux
avis défavorables et pour
qui et contre qui savent cei n'est pas
adopté nous passons à 10 cet amendement
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
le vin se massant
bassil lesouef ces masses on peut faire
une présentation globale
si vous voulez je vais le retirer madame
la présidente je préfère prendre les
devants numéro est retirée
il nous passons aux trois rectifié
monsieur vincent
cet amendement n'est pas retirée du tout
et il répond à l'objection qu'avait fait
donc le la rapporteure du du
de la commission des lois bon cette fois
c'est bien l ordonnance que je m'en
prends il ya tous les articles
ordonnance donc on peut pas dire qu'on
n'est pas d'accord
si on refuse de voter un amendement qui
supprime fallait des amendement qui
supprime les uns après les autres tous
les articles de l'ordonance et moi
j'estime que cette ordonnance il faut la
réduire à néant donc c'est le sens de
mes amendements
alors nous passons
profité ni
écoutés comme le 1 le premier a été
retirée n'a rempli de discussion commune
donc aurait demandé l'avis de la
commission puisque le premier justifier
la discussion commune
oh
on les maintient à
ouidah retirer il retire tous les
amendements non non non comme en fait
l'amendement le premier événement on a
été retiré cet amendement justifier la
discussion commune comme il a été retiré
nous deux ans maintenant mettre à l'avis
de la commission et du gouvernement
chaque amendement séparément leur
dommage d'avoir retiré fin voilà désolé
mais
et le retrait du premier mais voilà
enfin pour déclenchement cela donc le 3
rectifier de toute façon c'est un avis
défavorable
il n'est pas question d'abroger
l'ordonnancé il n'est pas question
d'abroger chaque article de l'ordonnancé
il était question du débat il est une
vague et la commission a proposé la non
ratification parce qu'elle manque
d'éléments il y a encore des chantiers
réglementaires affaire il y a des
missions qui ne sont pas encore qui
n'ont pas encore rendu leur rapport je
pense par exemple à la mission basser
madame la ministre a créé une nouvelle
mission aussi sur l'attractivité la
fonction publique nous manquons
d'informations pour ratifier il est hors
de question d'abroger donc c'est un avis
défavorable pour l'ensemble des
amendements il m'a même la rapporteure
madame la ministre
alors voilà président le jeu vous
propose comme je vais avoir un avis
constant sur les seize ou dix sept
amendements qui suivent de vous dire que
d'ores et déjà je suis défavorable à
l'ensemble d'entre eux
je profite peut être d'avoir ici la
parole pour dire aux sénateurs de tous
les bancs qu'évidemment le chantier
réglementaire se poursuit et qu'il est
important que je puisse autant que de
besoin
venir vous rencontrer en commission des
lois ou dans tout autre format pour que
je puisse évidemment vous détailler la
manière dont nous sommes pas en train de
déconstruire un système est bien de
reconstruire dans un esprit qui est
celui de 1945 qui est celui évidemment
de la défense de la république et de son
unité de son efficacité de sa proximité
et que je tiens ici donc à dire que je
ne m'exprimerai pas sur les amendements
qui viennent mais que je me tiens
évidemment à la disposition de ceux et
celles qui souhaiteraient connaître en
détail la manière dont nous allons
mettre en oeuvre les principes qui sont
dans cette ordonnance c'est évidemment
pour moi absolument nécessaire d'être à
votre disposition ce sujet majeur
merci alors je mets ou voient le 3
rectifié qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour et qui est
contre ça le sien il n'est pas adopté
monsieur masson vous présenter le 4
rectifié
[Musique]
blablate résidents de mon amendement
s'inscrit dans la logique du précédent
je constate que la commission est là
l'ensemble de mes collègues sont très
heureux d'avoir discuté par deux heures
pour rien du tout bon bah pif a décidé
pendant deux heures où on va discuter
encore 5 minutes de plus tous voir mes
amendements les uns après les autres je
vous remercie donc nous mettons voit le
4e rectifie qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables un débours qui contre qui
celle-ci n'est pas adoptée le 5 rectifié
monsieur mais sombre il est défendu
comme on a perdu de temps compte retenu
un petit peu à perdre nos tentes donc
mon amendement - amendement il défendu
et et je le maintiens très bien je mets
aux voileux 5 rectifié car ces deux avis
défavorables qui et pour qui est qu on
s'abstient n'est pas adopté le 6
rectifié défendu monsieur poisson
[Musique]
vendu et c'est les mêmes observations
celle que j'ai déjà fait alors l'avis de
la commission du gouvernement étant les
mêmes le vote est le même même vote il
n'est pas adopté le 7 rectifie il est
défendu il est défendu mme gies dans tes
je redis que c'est le même argumentaire
que les précédents donc même avis même
vote il est défaut il est n'est pas
adopté le 8 rectifié défendu il est
défendu avec le même argument est le
même argumentaire que les précédents
dont je le mets aux voix avec deux avis
défavorables
même votre fils n'est pas adopté le 9
rectifié défendu
donc même avis même vote il n'est pas
adopté 10 rectifier mais défendu défendu
sa présidence même avis même vote il
n'est pas adopté 11 rectifié défendu il
est défendu madame la présidente mais la
vie même quand il n'est pas adoptée le
12 rectifié défendu il est il est
défendu mêmes ingrédients mais je vous
fais remarquer quand même au passage que
nous autres donations nous avons
relativement peu même très peu de temps
de parole et j'aurais pu prendre mes
deux minutes à chaque fois mais j'ai
quand même pitié de deux je compatis
avec les collègues qui ne partagent pas
mon voix nue non merci donc même avis de
la commission et du gouvernement même
vote s'il n'est pas adopté le 13
rectifié défendu et pan du même avis
mais vote il n'est pas adopté le 14
heures actifs cédés s'est pendu lui il
est défendu et ma vie même vote pas
adopter 15 rectifier des sans délai pour
du madame la présidente mais ma vie même
votre pas adapté ses actifs y est il est
défendu mais la présidente mais magie
même vote il n'est pas adopté le 17
rectifier et défendu oui il est défendu
également meubles mais ma vie même s'il
n'est pas adopté le 18 rectifier j'ai
défendu ma domaine il même s'il n'est
pas adopté je me suis
alors
je vais mettre au voir l'article unique
constituant l'ensemble de la proposition
de loi le vote sur l'article vaudra vote
sur l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
yat-il les demandes d'explications de
vote monsieur sueur
monsieur sua
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
il est probable qu à une large majorité
le texte ne sera pas ratifié
la question maintenant je veux vous la
poser à vous en face
c'est très important
dès lors que sur un texte
qui a autant de conséquences
une assemblée du parlement le refuge
ce qui est son droit et nous considérons
son devoir je le considère comme tel
que va faire le gouvernement qu'allez
vous faire et je vous demanderai une
réponse précise
il y a deux solutions pour le
gouvernement
la première
c'est de prendre acte de cela
et à minima de saisir l'assemblée
nationale
ce qui permettrait qu'il y ait un débat
à l'assemblée nationale puis une
commission mixte paritaire
et si elle n'aboutissait pas un nouveau
débat devant l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat l'assemblée nationale ayant le
dernier mot
dans ce cas
vous répondriez que le parlement dans
son ensemble
serait saisi d'un sujet aussi essentiel
pour la république
première solution j'espère que vous
l'adopterez que vous nous l'allemand
serez ici
deuxième solution
madame la ministre deuxième solution
jean adresse à vous personnellement
vous dit
la position du sénat n'aura aucune
conséquence
comme vous savez dit tout à l'heure à
cette tribune c'est irréversible
si cette irréversible alors que l'une
des deux assemblées du parlement
a marqué son désaccord avec des
arguments forts
ça pose un problème réel
et je vous dis en face que si vous
adoptiez cette seconde attitude ce
serait profondément anti républicain
merci messieurs questeur se donne la
parole à monsieur masson
je ne partage pas du tout l'avis notre
collègue sur la la constitution c'est la
constitution il ya des règles le
gouvernement est obligé à ce que fit si
la constitution n'est pas du tout obligé
parce que le sénat aura rejeté
ce texte de deux de le soumettre à
l'assemblée nationale enfin le sénat
n'avait qu'à assumer ses responsabilités
et rejeter l'ordonance tout le reste
c'est la mascarade on essaye de fait de
gesticuler pour faire croire qu'on fait
quelque chose au niveau du sénat mais
quel que soit le vote qu'on fera
aujourd'hui si c'est pour dire oui ou
pour dire non à l'artiste en question il
varie va rien se passer du tout ça est
rien c'est la même chose ce qu'il
fallait c'était prendre une position sur
l' ordonnance on l'a pas prise bah il
faut s'assumer moi je trouve que c'est
du cinéma tout ça et je participerai pas
au vote monsieur le président retailleau
pour explication de vote je voudrais
vraiment revenir sur la signification de
notre initiative commune et sur le vote
qui va avoir lieu je crois d'ailleurs
par scrutin public dans quelques
instants nous allons nouer d'autres voté
contre cette résolution parce que nous
voulons par là-même manifester notre
opposition à l' ordonnance et madame la
ministre depuis le début ou fait clean
de ne pas comprendre nous n'en pouvons
plus de la dépossession des pouvoirs du
parlement le recours incessant aux
ordonnances pour le gouvernement fait la
loi très bien mais y compris du temps du
général de gaulle et de ses successeurs
les ordonnances était ratifié ce qui
distingue aujourd'hui ce qui marque
votre empreinte de l'exercice des
ordonnances c'est que vous ne voulez
plus ratifié 18% de ratification donc
d'un côté toujours plus d'habilitation
et de l'autre côté toujours moins de
ratification c'est cela qui nous choque
et ça nous choque encore plus sur ce
projet d'ordonnancé qu'il s'agit d'une
réforme de la haute fonction publique de
notre administration est donc de l'état
dans la crise civique de démocratie que
traverse la france on le voit la montée
la défiance vis-à-vis de l'état il faut
refaire l'état il faut refaire l'état
pour donner à l'état plus de puissance
de protection plus d'impulsion et nous
pensons que ce que nous avait ce que
vous nous avez dit ce que vous allez
proposer ne réglera rien du tout mais
absolument rien du tout c'est une forme
comment dirais-je de vision ce dos
managériale qui ne collera pas avec
l'émission de long terme de l'état
madame c'est ce que nous avons voulu
dire mais avant tout notre vote sera une
protestation contre la dépossession des
droits du parlement contre le mépris que
vous avez si bien exprimé ce matin dans
le figaro madame si bien exprimé je vous
remercie de l'avoir fait c'est très
éclairant et en même temps et en même
temps parce que nous voulons nous
opposer à cette vision quête une vision
finalement très technocratique et kittin
vision qui fait que le politique abdique
son courage sa responsabilité et se
défausse sur la haute fonction publique
et je voudrais dire à tous ces
fonctionnaires quelques niveaux qu'ils
soient qui sont l'honneur du pays est
que très franchement cette haute
fonction publique en france mais par le
monde elle est enviée par beaucoup de
pays merci maintenant l'état monsieur
médevielle
merci madame la présidente
la période pré électorale présidentielle
soit une période agitée
j'ai parlé de balle dans mon propos on
entend des balles siffler puisque des
balles perdues et nous offre parfois des
alliances étonnantes
ce que ce qu'on regrette
c'est que cette alliance n'est pas été
en mesure de formuler des propositions
de formuler des amendements à part
monsieur masson
ça a été une alliance d'une alliance de
blocage une alliance de refus
cette réforme nous l'appelions de tous
nos voeux la droite et le centre nous
avons voté
l'habilitation
et nous allons rester lisible crédible
moi je sais pas si les gens qui ont
regardé la séance combien exactement ce
qui se passe et il reste est claire ce
qui serait fort moi je le redis nous
l'appelions de tous nos voeux et donc
nous voterons pour en grande majorité
dans mon bon
merci madame la présidente
nous avons abordé ce débat avec toute
l'objectivité qui était possible force
est de constater que les arguments des
uns et des autres et les vôtres matin la
ministre ne nous permettent pas de voter
ce texte notre groupe ne participera pas
au vote
je vous remercie ses collègues juste
donne maintenant la parole à madame
kuperman pour explication madame la
présidente madame la ministre quelques
remarques effectivement parce que je
crois qu'il nous faut du pet personnes
il y as mais nous avons été un certain
nombre à le dire un débat de forme et un
débat de fond donc bien évidemment nous
ne voterons pas cette proposition de loi
pour les raisons que j'ai rappelé
l'intervention général que ma collègue
marine alignement l'a rappelé que bien
d'autres ont rappelé
le recours excessif
abusif parfois même aux ordonnances la
possibilité aujourd'hui à creux de nos
ratification est qui mais je veux le
redire ici pose un véritable souci de
séparation des pouvoirs année après
année deuxièmement parce que sur le fond
nous ne partageons pas votre vision de
la réforme de la fonction publique
d'ailleurs dans son ensemble et plus
particulièrement en ce qui nous
intéresse ici ce soir de la haute
fonction de la haute fonction publique
qui doit avant tout et surtout
rester ce qui fait effectivement la
grandeur d'un état d'un état qui doit
répondre au nombre des fier aux enjeux
de demain mais en le travaillant dans la
continuité je ne reprends pas enfin je
veux simplement s'il le fallait rassurer
je crois que il n'ya aucune alliance
contre nature et que le sénat
régulièrement j'aurais envie de dire
c'est sur un certain nombre de
propositions de lois sur des amendements
sur un certain nombre de rapports voter
de façon
parfois unanime en tout cas
régulièrement avec des votes que l'on
qualifie les uns et les autres trans
partisan à l'image d'ailleurs de ce qui
peut se passer dans un certain nombre de
nos communes et de composition d'équipé
municipale
donc ne les sont ni hystérie z'ont pas
une situation qui n'a pas lieu d'être
oui il y a oh ce soir comme à d'autres
moments il y a eu et comme il y aura
d'autres une rencontre entre plusieurs
groupes politiques qui font le même vote
je crois que c'est aussi ça savoir à
prendre les bonnes décisions en
s'inspirant des réalités vécues
si chaque collègue
oui monsieur patriat vous avez la parole
un homme la présidente maintenant les
ministes merci
l'europe et des pays bien entendu votre
hâle texte pour trois raisons la
première raison c'est que cette réforme
de la fonction publique la même lit ça
très bien rappelé elle est demandée
depuis des années voire des dizaines
d'années que tout le monde souhaitait
s'y atteler et personne ne l'a fait et
qu'enfin elle répond aux nécessités de
notre temps la deuxième raison c'est le
gouvernement certains disques qui va
trop vite aujourd'hui mais le
gouvernement tient ses engagements
c'est pas si souvent que pour les
gouvernements hôtes et leur engagement
et quand il les tient de vous trouvez
qu'il détient dans la précipitation lors
qu'il l'ait fait après avoir beaucoup
consulté et que cette réforme répond à
des impératifs reconnu la troisième dans
nos carnets n'y a pas de nos clients n'y
a pas d'alliances contre nature il ya
des l'alliance de la carpe et du lapin
mais nous y sommes habitués quand le
seul projet de l'opposition sénat s'est
tous contre mâcon s'est tous contre le
gouvernement pour qu'il fasse ses sujets
la réprobation à négation à votre contre
je le dis si on amitié à tous les
collègues ici et de une fois de plus
cela ce soir ça va tourner un peu
ridicule quand les français
s'apercevront que les tenants d'une
proposition de loi qu'ils ont eux même
déposé ici ils ont au bout du compte
voter contre il y aura peut-être n'ont
pas de quoi rire mais de quoi faire
réfléchir merci
alors s'il n'y a plus de demandes
d'explication veulent je donne la parole
à madame la ministre qui souhaitait
s'exprimer sur ces interventions
très vite mal à la présidence mais moi
je continue d'affirmer que cette réforme
est nécessaire
qu'elle a été promise par tous les
gouvernements qui nous ont précédés que
nous avons été au bout de la rédaction
d'une réforme qui a été validée
d'ailleurs par le conseil d'état qui a
été au déposée qui avait fait l'objet de
très nombreuses consultations
et je tiens à dire monsieur monsieur
retailleau chez président retailleau
vous adresser aux fonctionnaires mais
dans le programme du parti qui est le
vôtre
il est écrit en toutes lettres que vous
voulez supprimer le statut des
fonctionnaires est ce que vous avez dit
malheureusement je crois ne pourra pas
convaincre les français puisqu'il a pas
de contre projet concret et c'est bien
là tout l'enjeu il aurait été je crois
de l'honneur du parlement de pouvoir
décider soit de ratifier soit d'abroger
mais j'ai l'impression que là nous
n'avons pas de réponse claire sur ce que
vous auriez fait maintenant que nous
vous exprimer par un vote qui n'est pas
très lisible en tout cas j'étais
heureuse de pouvoir venir vous en parler
et je serai évidemment heureuse revenir
vous en parler si vous me invité dans
les mois et les semaines qui viennent
je vous remercie et j'ai
gtc
chez
je pense qu'on va pouvoir maintenant
passer au vote j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
socialiste
écologiste et et républicains et le
groupe du rd pays sur l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement
le scrutin est ouvert voici le résultat
du scrutin numéro 1 sur l'ensemble du
texte compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifié la présidence nombre de votants
276 nombre de suffrages exprimés
257 pour l'adoption prendre 2 contre 225
la proposition de loi n'est pas adoptée
[Musique]